with jobs coming back you or maybe a
family member may still be out of work
and you may be blaming your age
it is a problem we've heard about a lot
here at eight news now with many people
in their 40s 50s and 60s saying
they can't find a job with businesses
always choosing younger candidates
so what can you do about it the i-team's
david charns with some answers and one
woman's story
[Music]
it's hard i've been looking for a job
nothing come up like so many in the
valley lusan telfa lost her job amid the
pandemic
she worked as a cashier at the fiesta
henderson and now at 62
with the casino closed she's having a
hard time finding work
except for my age maybe they hire
younger people but i will do the same
thing like
younger people do she tells us she's
applied to nearly two dozen jobs
but no takers so far and on top of it
all
she's caring for her husband and her two
college age kids
i can't sleep how can i pay my bills
my mortgage all everything
post-pandemic everyone's feeling it
particularly marginalized groups cara
jenkins is the administrator with the
nevada equal rights commission
believe it or not federal law considers
ageism to begin at age
40. when it comes to looking for work
she says
proof is key it's usually covert so it's
like
well you know right now we're just not
hiring or
we've found someone else and so we look
at the evidence and see who that someone
else is
out of about 400 age cases received
since
2018 just four met the standard for
ageism
we even get folks saying well it could
be it can't be anything other than my
age i'm a great worker it's not
race it's not anything else it's gotta
be because of my age
that's not enough we need the evidence
as for telfa
she says she's not given up she can't
afford to
i will find a job doesn't matter i'm 62
they didn't call me back
but i was fine finding a job and hopeful
someone will take a chance no matter her
age
i'm david charns 8 news now in a letter
to employees station casinos which owns
fiesta henderson said the new
right to return law favors part-time
workers over full-time workers
makes it harder for casinos which are
closed to reopen if you think
ageism played a role in trouble you're
having finding a job
you can file a complaint on the nevada
equal rights commission website